one of the things that I can I I do feel
uh that we have some things in common
which is
one of the things I love about my career
which is very different from yours but I
love that I get to do things
I get put in situations where I get to
do something I'd never get to do
otherwise right and I know that actors
ex have experienced that a lot and I
love
whenever I get to
um be put in some situation I've been
shooting a travel some travel pieces
recently and I find myself
you know kickboxing in Thailand and I
think how could this have happened yeah
you know I come from Boston
Massachusetts yeah
um my parents were nothing near show
business I love that part of it and I
know that
you know for example uh for the second
season of of Perry Mason which I adore
you got to ride a vintage motorcycle is
that right yes yeah are you are you a
motorcycle guy this will color the way I
answer this question okay I'll tell you
this yeah I do have a motorcycle uh I
don't I have all these rules about when
I ride it because I I want my kids to
yes I want to meet my grandchildren yes
but
um I recently was in a very exotic
location and they found a a
motorcycle for me to ride for this one
shot and it was a 1956 BMW
in Bangkok and I just was looking at
this thing it's one of the most
beautiful things I've ever seen in my
life and then you ride it and you think
[Music]
I really like the improvements they've
made yes I like the look of this thing
oh the I love the look yes but what did
you get to ride so it was a 19 the 1933
Harley-Davidson right
um and and it took a course very quickly
so they said they said uh we were
talking about what what we're going to
do with Mason and they said what do you
like dream scenario what would you get
to do in this and I said look I I do
love being on a horse I've always loved
horses if you can find your way until
everything find Mason under a horse
that'd be great but in a courtroom scene
yes I was like now there's your
challenge yes that's what I've noticed
about the new season that threw me a bit
is you're often on Horseback in the
courtroom yes exactly
yes there was a lot of objections it
takes me out of the I know everyone said
that
um
so so one of the writers one of the
writers was in is is an enormous you
know motorbike fan so he said I'm gonna
you know we have we're gonna Mason on a
motorbike bro great so then they the
stunt coordinated calls Memphis can you
ride a motorbike I said it can I said
I've had to ride a vintage one before
they said great come down we're going to
do a test day you know weeks before okay
great let's go down producers there
everyone's there and there's the Bali
guy and he's like Okay so
you hold this and then pull that in now
stay obviously well obviously you'll
have pumped this first and I'm like
right then then you go for the right now
now the kickstarter as that's Kickstart
timing time right turn that turn turn
turn I was like this will never work
can't you get me something that looks
like this but it just has an on off
switch yes and uh and it has an
automatic transmission
so so that was established very quickly
I did so they got the stunt man to ride
it uh for a second uh and no one could
hear anything everyone's going I can't
hear over the noise of this thing right
this time I said oh this whoa this is
tricky right
yeah right oh this is dangerous yeah I
would I wouldn't want to ride this thing
yeah so the producers very quickly went
turn to the action vehicle team and went
how much would it cost no how long would
it take to turn this into an electric
bike
there were audible gasps from certain
male members of this yes yes you've been
emasculated oh so they took it away and
they turned it into an e-bike
so very often out on set it was it was
still this beautiful night night this
shell of a thing 1933 Harley that had
all these all these batteries you know
squirreled away about it
and very often we were on location in
various places around L.A and I'd be on
the thing kind of warming you know doing
little laps and stuff like that and
gentlemen of usually a certain age would
come up and go whoa whoa whoa what what
is that and I was like well it's it's a
it's a 1933 Harley Davidson and they go
yeah but it's not an original they
wouldn't have done that to an original
and I went
yes they have
because I asked them yes and some it was
met with a very great mix of reverence
for the for the engineering that would
have gone into turning into an e-bike an
abject disgust to the butchering of some
American history the uh I'm also
thinking of you know most people want
the Harley
in any era because of that distinctive
Harley sound and I imagine this thing
sounded like
and little bubbles came out yes it was
like it was like
and then warning battery low yes
embarrassing sounds come out of it yeah
yeah and it would tell you when you
needed you know another coffee or
something or something like that so it
was it was it was good and both bad yeah
and then the other the flip side of that
was when they said we're gonna write
we're gonna write this uh we're gonna
write this scene where you're in Santa
Ana race track on a thoroughbred and I
was like why are you doing what though
and they went well you're Galloping
around the track and I said yeah yes but
I I won't get to Gallup that'll be a
stunt man they won't allow me to do that
and they went
oh sorry well we've written it so cut
two is me on the most this is probably
one of the most humiliating moments they
kind of got me this
it was used in Seabiscuit but it's
basically like an adult rocking horse
that's attached to the back of a pickup
and yeah so there's a stuntman riding a
horse it looks amazing and then they cut
in for the tight shot of Perry Mason yes
and um you're on basically uh a carpet
yeah a horse-colored carpet has been
laid over a fake horse back yeah and
that's it and it rocks a little bit yes
and they and they sort of and then the
horse ranking team kind of sit with you
while you they try and talk you through
how you should be looking on this adult
hobby horse it was that was a that was a
bat that was a bad day
I didn't enjoy that date but then you
asked could I have this please yes and
they said yes of course take it we call
it biscuit because if they do it was
built for Sea Biscuit I'd like to uh I
like riding but it feels a little
dangerous now and so yes big love you
know what I love it if you just went out
in the country so and and you know
Carrie and the family are on the truck
and you're just in the back yes
pretending to pretending to Gallery Oh I
thought this is what I genuinely wanted
I said I would pay if if this was
allowed I would pay good money to go up
and down Hollywood Boulevard in this
pickup and I'm just on the back giving
it the full
and they didn't even answer they just
looked at me yeah